we have a voicemail number that number
is a two one nine two david p i got a
voicemail early this morning i actually
don't know what this person is talking
about i just i think they're mad at me
it's not clear for what see if you can
help me figure it out you are so
freaking foolish the only station is fox
news you have NBC ABC the freakin
newspaper and you want to say the only
station that was for you for against you
is fox news you people are so freakin
pathetic i don't even know how you live
with yourself
i really don't know what this person is
talking about i'm trying to think of
what i said I don't know that I've ever
said Fox News is the only anything it's
not the only pro-trump media outlet it's
certainly not a liberal media outlet
it's not I mean I I just have no idea
what this person is talking about if
somebody has a better recollection from
from last week's shows and you maybe can
tell me what it is this person's talking
about please let me know because I have
no clue what it is
okay we have a very important bonus show
today every day we do an additional show
so there's the show that is ending soon
and then there's the next bonus show
which is every single day for our paid
subscribers okay we are going to talk
about qualified immunity for police
accused of misconduct this is a really
important apparatus that were it removed
or limited would make it easier to go
after police when they behave badly the
Supreme Court is weighing qualified
immunity we're going to talk about it on
today's bonus show number two Fox News
put up this crazy graphic essentially
showing how well the stock market
sometimes does when there are tragic
incidents like black people being killed
by police or riots or different things
we are now going to tell you not only
what the graph said but Fox News has
apologized and hey you know what Trump
never apologizes at least Fox News is
apologizing that's something we can say
then lastly the editor of the New York
Times has resigned after backlash over
an editorial written and published
written by Republican Senator John
cotton Tom cotton and published by the
New York Times blowback has now led to
the editor James Bennett resigning is
this the right thing we are going to
talk about all of those stories and more
on today's bonus show get instant access
by becoming a member at join pakman.com
and remember to get the daily free
podcast on itunes google play Spotify
Pandora stitcher or whatever podcasting
program or app you prefer the daily
audio podcast a very popular way of
consuming the show for many of our
viewers I encourage you to check it out
we'll see you on the bonus show